this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer richard wakeling death is
ingrained to every aspect of sifu as
you'll die
die
and die again before licking your wounds
and returning to the fray for another
seemingly misguided attempt at emerging
from a fight unscathed sifu is a
punishingly difficult game that won't
appeal to everyone it requires a mastery
of its combat mechanics so those looking
for a challenging game that demands
skill and improvement from the player
will find it's an excellent modern
beat-em-up with deep combat mechanics
and a fascinating aging system
it's worth noting that sifu's combat
provides the basis for everything else
that comes after it is primarily a game
where your sole focus revolves around
not getting hit you'll have a variety of
defensive techniques at your disposal
with each one pivotal depending on the
situation holding the block button for
sustained defense is the simplest way to
avoid taking a crack to the skull but
this only works for a matter of seconds
both you and your enemies have meters
for structure which functions a lot like
sekiro's posture system you can block
attacks as long as your structure
remains intact but taking too many hits
will eventually break it and leave you
wide open for enemies to capitalize on
your mistake you can parry attacks to
prevent your structure from breaking by
tapping the block button before a blow
connects but you need to be aware of
when your assailant's combo ends to have
any success of halting the momentum
parrying the first attack they launch
won't leave them open to a counter
attack if they're going to follow up
that attack with a couple more so you
might have to parry three attacks in a
row before you can retaliate with a
rapid fire counter being able to
recognize and learn the types of combos
each enemy type uses is the only way
parrying multiple strikes in succession
is feasible which makes it difficult to
achieve when you're first learning the
ropes fortunately dodging doesn't cost
anything to use allowing you to dash out
of harm's way when the situation calls
for a little breathing room this doesn't
muster quite the same level of
satisfaction as successfully parrying an
assault does but both techniques also
pale in comparison to the pure elation
that comes from avoiding attacks while
standing in place by holding the block
button and pushing the left stick in any
direction you can use slight body
movement to slip punches and duck under
head kicks to avoid taking any damage at
all the timing on this is relatively
forgiving so it quickly becomes a
crucial tool in your arsenal whether
you're fighting a rowdy group of enemies
or a single tough-as-nails foe being
able to avoid an entire combo without
taking a step backwards is a phenomenal
feeling particularly when you follow it
up with a devastating counter-attack of
your own when you start ducking and
weaving to avoid an enemies combo and
then combine this with a parry to greet
their final attack everything starts to
click into place and you really feel
like a martial arts expert
[Music]
the only time defending comes undone is
when the camera actively works against
you since whenever you're backed up
against the wall it's very likely that
you won't be able to see anything at all
it's just all the more glaring in sifu
when one mistake can prove fatal
when it comes to offensive options sifu
opts for simplicity with most of its
combos utilizing two buttons for light
and heavy attacks performing a leg sweep
to take an enemy off their feet requires
you to move the left stick down and then
up before finishing with a heavy attack
but it never gets more complicated than
that it's all fairly straightforward
almost out of necessity so much of your
time is spent focusing on the defensive
side of each fight that being able to
strike back with relative ease is a
blessing and combat is no less exciting
because of it either sifu is built on an
aggressive style of kung fu known as pak
mei which is about putting your opponent
on the ground and ensuring that they
stay there it's not overly flashy so you
won't be wowed by flamboyant combos and
indulgent attacks instead sifu impresses
by capturing the tangible sense of
impact behind each crunching blow your
attacks are often lightning fast
breaking through rib cages and jaw bones
with a wince inducing ferocity that
makes each successful hit feel
incredibly satisfying the environments
you're fighting in serve a function as
well so being aware of your surrounding
is a key aspect to see through these
fisticuffs you might roll over a
tabletop or scale a mezzanine to create
separation from a group of enemies or
isolate a single foe ottomans and stalls
exist to be kicked taking out opponents
knees while brooms and pieces of broken
wood act as makeshift weapons there's
also a takedown system that activates
when you break through an enemy
structure giving you the chance to
launch into a rapid-fire finishing move
that makes contextual use of the
environment to finish off your enemy in
brutal fashion performing takedowns is
the only way to refill a fraction of
your health bar but there's a risk
reward element at play too some enemies
will simply refuse to be beaten by
reversing your takedown and gaining a
buff in the process suddenly you're
fighting someone with increased health
who hits harder and uses new more
dangerous techniques but defeating these
souped-up enemies has its own benefits
by removing a year from your death
counter whether you choose to play as a
male or female character you'll find
yourself in possession of a magical
pendant that allows you to get back up
and continue fighting after your health
bar has been fully depleted the catch
behind this apparent indestructibility
is that each time you do so more years
are stripped away from your life the
more frequently you die raising your
aforementioned death counter in the
process the more your age will increase
with each subsequent demise die four
times in a row for instance and your age
will increase by four years the next
time you fail you might begin the game
as a fresh-faced 20 year old but by the
end of the first chapter you'll likely
find yourself rocking the salt and
pepper look as you heave into your 50s
once you hit the ripe old age of 70 the
next death will be your last as
dependence magic fades and sends you to
a game over screen aside from being able
to see the physical changes of this
rapid aging the decades-long
transformation also has some gameplay
implications too as you reach the
twilight years of your life your maximum
health decreases while your damage
output increases the idea is that as the
body ages those fragile bones can't
quite sustain as much punishment as they
could before but you're also wiser and
able to dish out more retribution with
the learned experience of a lifetime of
combat pulsating behind each fist
there's a fairly robust skill tree that
lets you spend experience to add things
like new combos or unlock abilities to
catch projectiles out of midair and
these upgrades are certainly useful
while also diversifying your moveset but
they're not integral to your progression
your own skill level will dictate how
far you're able to make it through
sifu's five chapters with success
predicated on the ways in which you're
able to adapt and learn how to approach
each enemy type and situation sifu's
aging mechanic means you'll inevitably
replay most fights multiple times until
each room is approached with a mixture
of improvisation and foresight
completing a chapter means you'll begin
the next one at whatever age you finish
the last whether that means you're 31 or
68. the youngest age you start a chapter
is always saved so you can return to
previous chapters without having to
worry about losing a vital checkpoint
this is key since you need to complete
the entire game before dying in your 70s
you'll regularly return to past chapters
in order to try and finish them at a
younger age and give yourself more
leeway moving forward this sounds like a
daunting task but there are a few
shortcuts along the way to break up the
combat and provide a little breather
sifu touches on some investigative
elements by scattering pieces of
evidence within each level most of this
stuff is superfluous since the
threadbare story isn't fleshed out by
these tidbits of information you will
however also find keys and door codes
that will regularly open up shortcuts
allowing you to bypass huge sections of
a level on repeat visits this makes
seafood structure more palatable since
you're not forced to replay entire
levels over and over again the story
itself is your boilerplate revenge tale
as our unnamed protagonist is out for
vengeance against the five kung fu
masters who kill their father the
protagonist is a personality vacuum and
you don't spend enough time with each of
the five bosses for them to leave a mark
ultimately this isn't any sort of deal
breaker since the basic setup is all you
really need to justify sifu's compelling
gameplay loop however it is
disappointing that the narrative doesn't
delve into the ramifications of using
the magical pendant and confront whether
vengeance is worth an entire lifetime
your journey from student to master in
sifu is thrilling mainly because it's
governed by your own improving skill
level rather than traditional character
progression there are memorable moments
that stand out throughout such as boss
fights and an enjoyable recreation of
the iconic hallway scene from oldboy but
it's sifu's combat that shines through
most brightly for as unique and
interesting as its aging mechanic is it
wouldn't work without combat carrying
the load and ensuring that each replay
is just as engaging as the last is one
life enough to know kung fu maybe not
but i would happily spend mine playing
seafood to find out
[Music]